the impeachment hearings picked up again
today you know just another day of
bickering Congress people and a bunch of
dry evidence being read into record like
businesses like an actual highlight by
conditioning a desperately sought oval
office meeting and 391 million dollars
in taxpayer-funded congressionally
appropriated security assistance it was
really really boring so as he guess not
many people watched it in fact it was so
boring here's some of the programming on
other networks at the same time that
easily beat the impeachment hearings in
the ratings the Food Network got better
ratings with their six our corn sorting
marathon yeah yeah true story TV land
beat the impeachment hearings with this
footage of all the exterior shots from
Seinfeld
[Applause]
that ended before I wanted it to enjoy
do it again yeah yeah come on let's see
that again I could watch that all day
Animal Planet beat them with their show
exhausted zebras of the Serengeti he's
sleeping we wouldn't show you a dead
zebra we let it play extra long so you
could see it breathing yeah everyone
just thought we're the kind of show
yesterday run footage of a dead zebra
right what kind of monsters do you think
we are
we tried that footage is way too
expensive
Telemundo BTS Pietschmann hearings with
this screensaver of a floating Enya
[Music]
at feat ESPN to beat them with
competitive pool cue chalking the
History Channel beat them with their
show 80 years of sailors looking through
binoculars
[Music]
you can't see this at home but the crowd
is actually filing out hey there's more
finally vh1 beat the impeachment
hearings with their special remembering
the first time we heard seal as a
JCPenney and there was a song playing
over yeah I liked it okay so I asked one
of the cashiers what it was he said he
didn't know there was just some service
they used the pipe in music then a few
weeks later I heard it on the radio and
the DJ said it was seal so I stopped by
Walmart on my way home from work and
picked up the CD and some cream for my
feet so that's that's how I heard Seal
[Applause]